[Musique]
belle mais où est la réalité c'est
aérotrain qui se déplace sur un matelas
d'air à quelques centimètres du sol
est ce la réalité d'aujourd'hui ou celle
de demain débarrassé de tout contact
avec la terre il est capable de se
déplacer à 600 km à l'est de relier
paris à lyon en 45 minutes
restera-t-il un jouet une maquette ou le
prendrons nous demain comme nous prenons
aujourd'hui le métro l'autobus et
pourquoi ne pas imaginer que cette
technique de déplacement sur des
coussins d'air puisse être utilisé pour
d'autres moyens de transport pour les
voitures par exemple voici ce qu'en dit
son constructeur
monsieur bertin
j'ai entendu dire parfois que il était
inutile de construire des autoroutes que
toute façon dans 10 ou 15 ans tous les
véhicules s'arrêtent à coussin d'air et
qu'il suffirait d'avoir des espaces plan
pour pour qu'ils se déplacent
qu'est ce que vous en pensez enfin pour
le moment c'est une notion je ne vous ai
pas la qualifier trop sévèrement
enfin elle est sûrement complètement
erroné dans dans l'est dans l'optique de
ce qu'on peut faire avec les coussins
d'air actuellement je pense que là où
les coussins verts ont de très gros
chance comme je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure c'est pour l'aérotrain par
exemple et qui est après tout un
transport public qui n'est pas un
transport individuel également le
premier débouché des machines libre des
aéroglisseurs livre nous le voyons sur
la manche par exemple ou pour la corse
encore une fois c'est un transport
public collectif des machines individuel
utilisable sur terre à la demande
des particuliers en toutes circonstances
nous ne voyons pas comment elle pourrait
fonctionner est annexée machine à côté
de leur très grande qualité ont un gros
défaut c'est qu'elles n'ont pas de
pouvoir directionnel on appelle pouvoir
directionnel la faculté d'un flux même à
grande vitesse rapidement sur la
position qu'elle occupe un moment donné
par rapport au sol c'est ce qui permet
un automobiliste d'éviter le celui qui
vient en face quelquefois 10 cm plaît
parce que en quelques centièmes de
seconde
il a pu gagner les 10 ou 20 cm qu'il lui
fallait pour l'éviter on n'imagine pas
le nombre d'accidents qui sont évités
par cette faculté
un aéroglisseur ne l'a pas par
conséquent nous ne voyons pas comment
une circulation de nombreuses
aéroglisseur sur une piste où une voie
de du genre autoroute vous faites pour
eux pour les produits nous ne voyons
vraiment pas
[Musique]
à la préfecture du rhône
hier après-midi un certain nombre de
responsables régionaux ont étudié la
possibilité de relier lyon saint-etienne
et grenoble à la vitesse de 300 km heure
il ne s'agit pas de science fiction mais
et d'un nouveau mode de transport
l'aérotrain mis au point par une équipe
française que dirige monsieur jean
berthe l'inventeur et ses collaborateurs
ont présenté une maquette aux personnes
présentes parmi lesquelles messieurs
ricard préfet de région grève préfet de
la loire doublé préfet de l'isère et le
maire de lyon au monsieur pas d'elle
ainsi que celui de grenoble
monsieur du but cette nouvelle
réalisation qui intéresse déjà très
vivement les américains verra peut-être
le jour dans notre région entre lyon et
grenoble ou bien lyon et saint-etienne
monsieur jean bertin nous présente
maintenant les principales
caractéristiques de l'aérotrain il n'ya
pas d'organe qui sont en contact avec la
voix la voiture est supporté par des
coussins d'air ici est guidé également
par des coussins d'air ces coussins des
as sont clés par des ventilateurs
actionnées par des moteurs etc des
puissances est limité et une fois que
cette ce guidage 7 sustentation était
ont été obtenues la machine peut aller à
peupler la vitesse qu'on veut c'est
certainement un des moyens les moins
chères d'obtenir une grande vitesse mais
vous c'est sale je crois ce qu'il faut
retenir
qu'attendez vous pour grande vitesse
pour les autres et bien entre 200 et 400
kilomètres à l'heure c'est à dire des
vitesses qui n'ont qui ont déjà été
obtenus bien sûr avec des véhicules à
roues mais en exploit isolé et non pas
en trafic de tous les jours
donc c'est pour une solution pour les
moyennes distances
essentiellement nous pensons que c'est
une solution pour délais
et distant des dix ans ils ont comprises
entre 50 et 200 300 km voilà c'est
l'ordre de grandeur qui nous paraît
favorable
nous allons maintenant demander aux
principaux responsables de notre région
si ce premier contact avec l'aérotrain
les a convaincus sur l'intérêt de ce
moyen de transport révolutionnaire
tout d'abord monsieur ricard préfet de
région préfet du rhône vous avez parlé
de procédé révolutionnaire par
définition les préfets ne sont pas très
favorables aux révolutions puisqu'ils
sont garants de l'ordre
mais en l'espèce je vais déroger aux
principes habituels
je suis absolument convaincu de
l'extrême intérêt que présente un tel
procédé
déjà il ya quelques mois à l'occasion
d'une réunion parisienne
j'avais pu me pencher sur le projet de
monsieur bertin et la réunion
d'aujourd'hui m'a convaincu bien plus
encore de l'extrême nécessité d'avoir
grâce à ce procédé
des relations extrêmement fréquentes
rapide entre les trois grandes villes et
qui font la capitale tricéphale de notre
région
lyon grenoble et saint-etienne
je souhaite que très bientôt nous
puissions nous réjouir à la pensée que
ce procédé va connaître une très rapide
une très heureuse réalisation monsieur
grève préfet de la loire vous savez que
les pouvoirs publics ont décidé de faire
de lyon une grande métropole régionale
ce sera une métropole qui polaire lyon
saint-etienne il est dans cette optique
absolument indispensable qui est des
légions abondante et rapide entre
saint-etienne et lyon
je crois que en dehors de la liaison
autoroutière qui a son intérêt
spécifique
la formule de l'aérotrain est capable de
résoudre un certain nombre de problèmes
de liaison entre les deux villes
à vitesse rapide monsieur dubé zoomer de
grenoble l'intérieur en train il est
évident de ville de l'importance de
lyon-grenoble séparé par un relief aussi
difficile mais améliorer les
communications au point permis par les
autres un risque de changer totalement
la nature des relations entre ces deux
villes
c'était il y a encore quelques jours
dans les ateliers de la compagnie
française uta au bourget les dernières
finitions de l'aérotrain orléans de 150
80 250 km/heure 80 passagers construits
en collaboration ut ac cannes ce
véhicule sur coussin d'air qui est le
premier héros train pour ce que dans le
monde
andré grandeur est destiné aux liaisons
intervilles à moyenne distance
il est caractérisé par un freinage
rapide et efficace réalisable au moyen
de ses patins à dispositif de rouler
tractable et motrices permet aux
véhicules d'effectuer une translation
latéral encore plus caractéristique
cette élise caréné elle est d'un
diamètre de 2 mètres 30
elle est probablement la plus grande
église caréné au monde
les essais de l'aérotrain débuteront dès
la fin de ce mois sur la voie de 18 km
de long implanté au nord d'orléans
ce matin c'était la présentation aux
journalistes voici l'intérieur de
l'aérotrain on peut dire que vous êtes
le turc aérotrain le conducteur de ces
terres autre date ou va être à lyon
quelles sont vos impressions là vous
êtes au poste de commande quelles sont
vos impressions
c'est toujours les mêmes impressions que
peuvent avoir les équipages d'essai
quand ils prennent en main la première
fois à la machine et ce que nous
espérons surtout maintenant c'est pour
approuver les performances que nous
avons a lancé et
pour aller à l'avant la vitesse et nous
pensons certainement atteindre deviner
sa vitesse annoncée c'est à dire des
croisières de 250 km ha été pointe de
300 km/heure certainement assez
rapidement pour la première fois les
lisent de l'aérotrain à tourner monsieur
bertin qui a conçu ce type sustentation
partout sein d'air explique pour quelles
raisons il s'est orienté vers ce mode de
transport
cette formule aérotrain a été voulu pour
offrir aux voyageurs père est un moyen
de transport en commun vraiment moderne
cette solution peut s'offrir aussi bien
les très grandes vitesses pour les
voyages intervilles pour les liaisons
intervilles qu'une très grande souplesse
pour les liaisons en zone urbaine ou
suburbaines il est certain qu'à ce
moment là la vitesse n'a pas le même
facteur d'intérêt que pour les liaisons
intervilles
c'est un élément du problème on peut
dire aujourd'hui également qu'après plus
de dix ans de recherches d'études et
d'essais
cette formule est maintenant prête pour
une exploitation l'air au train les
habitants de la région parisienne sont
enfin fixés aujourd'hui sur le parcours
défini le district parisiens avaient à
choisir soit la ligne qui ré de la
défense jusqu à cergy-pontoise soit pas
d'air au train du tout en définitive il
ya une demi-heure le district a voté par
33 voix contre 11
il a confirmé la création de cette ligne
le choix était long et difficile claude
carré et pierre moscovite je vous
explique pourquoi
[Musique]
250 kilomètres à l'heure depuis six ans
ses terres au train expérimental fait
des allers-retours solitaire près
d'orléans moyen de transport ultra
moderne
il est maintenant parfaitement au point
reste une question va-t-on bientôt
construire une première ligne
commerciale le gouvernement a dit oui
l'aérotrain est une invention française
il faut donc l'exploiter d'abord chez
nous pour notre confort et pour la faire
connaître à l'étranger et la revendre
avec bénéfice pour la france une ligne
sera donc créé près de paris cergy
pontoise la défense mais après la
décision du gouvernement le district
parisien qui s'occupe de l'aménagement
de toute la région parisienne doit
donner son accord
l'avenir de l'aérotrain se joue donc ici
dans cette salle au conseil
d'administration du district des
conseillers sont allés à orléans visitée
l'aérotrain et écoutez les explications
de son inventeur l'ingénieur bertin mais
il était mécontent
pourquoi disent-ils la région parisienne
seul devrait-elle financer aérotrain
dans la promotion concerne toute la
france alors que cette ligne ne
correspond pas aux besoins des usagers
de la banlieue le gouvernement les a
rassurés sur ce point le district ne
supportera pas seul le financement de la
ligne mais les élus sont aussi partagées
il avait d'autres projets ceux du sud ou
de l'est sont contraires au train ceux
de l'ouest pour regarder ses cartes
au départ le district préféré une ligne
à l'est entre le futur aéroport de
roissy et orly coût 600 millions de
francs
c'était trop cher pour l'état et le 29
juillet dernier le gouvernement
choisissait à l'ouest la ligne
cergy-pontoise la défense cette ligne
sera construite où il n'y aura aucun
aérotrain le choix donc est difficile
voici cette ligne coût 3 117 millions de
francs mais dans cette région le
district avait déjà prévu une nouvelle
voie ferrée qui dit il dessert mieux
cette banlieue canard au train rapide
qui ne s'arrête pas en chemin
de plus cette voie ferrée ne coûtait que
133 millions de francs au district
argent qui sera reversée à l'aérotrain
un héros train qui ne pourra fonctionner
qu'en 1976
un an plus tard que le train mais
l'aérotrain sera une chance pour la
promotion des villes nouvelles
sète hérault train sera le frère de
celui-ci filmé pour la première fois
gomes la ville moteurs linéaires 200
kilomètres à l'heure en croisière
quelles seront les répercussions de
cette nouvelle ligne pour les usagers
les opinions des élus là aussi sont
divisés parce que nous pensons que cergy
pontoise qui est une des nouvelles
risquent de devenir si elle s'est
ralliée par les murs un moyen très
rapide la défense la ville dortoir la
défense que les emplois soient à la
défense et et qu'on fasse on était là le
contre schéma directeur l'agente ride
mais nous sommes inquiets également en
ce qui concerne nos propres finances car
en effet l'exploitation de sète hérault
train sera coûteux il n'est pas évident
qu'il puisse absorber le nombre de
voyageurs qui nécessaire d'absorber et
nous risquons peut-être à terme et à
moyen terme de ne voir contraint de
financer en plus d'aéroports 1 une vrai
chemin de fer classique
nous ne voulons pas que les populations
la région par le truchement des impôts
payent la soul à la casse
dan d'une opération qui est intéressante
nationalement mais qui l'est beaucoup
moins volage embrasée il faut un aéro
train il vaut mieux l'aérotrain
cergy-pontoise que ne pas haïr train du
tout d'autant plus que les retraites
cergy pontoise est extrêmement important
il s'agit en effet d'une ville nouvelle
il faut lui donner des moyens de
transport modernes la ligne qui lierait
cergy à la défense alors que la défense
est maintenant saturé au point de vue
bureau aurait pour but par un système de
bipolarisation d'apporter à
cergy-pontoise des emplois nouveaux et
par conséquent tant au point de vue
transport qu'au point de vue la création
d'emplois nouveaux qui est la vocation
du district la ligne de cergy-pontoise
répond à ces conditions c'est la raison
le tgv est parti lentement de la
rochelle pour belfort où il va trouver
ses moteurs le tgv je crois que ça veut
dire le train à grande vitesse le plus
rapide du monde avec le tgv le turbo
trains à grande vitesse
la sncf espère franchir une nouvelle
étape dans l'augmentation de la vitesse
de pointe tout en améliorant confort et
sécurité une partie de la rame prototype
vient d'être réalisée à la rochelle dans
une usine de matériel ferroviaire
ces grandes vitesses nécessite des
conceptions spécial l'emploi d'acier à
haute limite élastique a permis de
réduire le poids 25 tonnes par voiture
contre 45 une voiture normale
la sonorisation était poussé au maximum
le conditionnement d'air et du type
aviation aux trois voitures construites
à la rochelle vont s'en ajouter deux
autres en cours de réalisation à belfort
la rame prototype comportera donc cinq
voitures dont deux motrices pilote
extrémité une voiture de première avec
34 place une voiture de 2e classe et une
voiture laboratoire une particularité du
tgv ses bogies son moteur le courant
électrique produit par les deux motrices
est envoyé dans les moteurs placés dans
les six bougies de la ram pour
constituer une sorte de chez nous les
premiers essais de vitesse sont prévues
entre mulhouse et belfort
le tgv doit rapidement atteindre les 200
à l'heure dans un premier temps pour
s'attaquer ensuite aux 300 km 300 km
heure c'est l'ambition de la sncf qui
veut en faire le train le plus rapide du
monde pour détrôner le tokaïdo et ses
210 km à l'est
[Musique]
le turbo temps résulte du mariage de
deux techniques très différentes la
technique ferroviaire et la technique
aéronautique en vue de créer un type de
véhicule capable de circuler à grande
vitesse sur des voies constitué
d'éléments classiques les éléments
nouveaux cet engin c'est évidemment la
turbine à gaz pourquoi la turbine à gaz
parce qu'il faut sur cet engin avoir
beaucoup de puissance pour aller vite
mais en même temps il faut alléger le
véhicule pas ce qui importe pour aller
vite s'ils n'ont pas la puissance hull
mais le rapport de la puissance à la
masse c'est à dire la puissance massique
la sensation de vitesse ressentie par le
voyageur dépendant seulement
l'impression visuelle mais d impression
de confort qui sont donnés par la
suspension et la sonorisation vitesse
oui en augmentant la sécurité
alors il ya un exemple mondial qui est
très important actuellement c'est celui
de kaboul sur le tokaïdo on roule depuis
huit ans à peu près je crois sans le
mois d' accident le niveau de bruit de
ce véhicule aux vitesses supérieures à
200 kilomètres à l'heure est inférieur
de 5 à 6 décibels au niveau de bruit
mesuré au même point pour un train
classique
monsieur gilles gard à combien le turbo
c'est à travers ce titre votre gamme en
général dans les 300 kilomètres là il ya
moins de déplacements d'elle que par
exemple un train avec une pièce qui a
fait à 140 alors que la vitesse doit
d'abord être praticable sans
augmentation des sensations du voyageur
mais elle doit également pour le
voyageur praticable sans augmentation de
la somme qui doit débourser ces rames
seront lancés à quelle époque et sur
quel trajet je peux parler des projets
qui sont prévues il s'agit de surtout de
paris lyon
la mise en service des turbines trains
permettrait d'abaisser le parcours paris
lyon le temps de parcours à 2h et
d'augmenter la fréquence également
considérablement de l'ordre de 30
allez retourne un jour c'est comme vous
l'avez vu nous venons de faire un nouvel
essai qui nous a permis d'atteindre
facilement la vitesse de 300 km à
l'heure et de la dépasser légèrement
puisque nous avons atteint 305
kilomètres à l'heure j'ai pu vous rendre
compte qu'à cette vitesse le
comportement de la ram et la suspension
de la cabine la tenue la stabilité de la
cabine était tout à fait satisfaisante
et que la circulation à l'hôtel vitesse
pour pour notre tour train expérimental
est quelque chose qui commence à devenir
de pratique assez courante
monsieur le ministre quelles sont vos
impressions et bien gt2 très frappé de
l'impression de vitesse que l'on a dans
la cabine
j'ai été aussi très frappé de que la
suspension la qualité de confort soit du
même ordre de grandeur que celles qu'on
peut avoir dans le mistral ou dans le
capitole à des vitesses très inférieurs
et par conséquent du fait que j'ai
l'impression que pourvu que la voie soit
adaptée et bien on est déjà presque dans
l'air d'exploitation industrielle de ces
très grandes vitesses ceux ci elle a été
très frappant courbes et pour vous c'est
un art ja de l'avenir c'est un signe de
la vitalité des la technique française
car cette technique n'a aucun équivalent
et c'est une extrêmement encourageant
non seulement pour l'avenir des
transports mais aussi pour l'avenir des
exportations monsieur le ministre vous
venez d'effectuer un parcours à bord du
tgv du turbo train en compagnie
d'ailleurs du secrétaire américain aux
transports quelles sont vos premières
impressions de passagers ses premières
impressions sont évidemment excellente
parce que c'est assez impressionnant
d'aller à 300 à l'heure et de ne pas
s'en apercevoir la rapidité la souplesse
le confort sont les caractéristiques du
turbo train et je pense que ce sont les
réactions également de mon collègue le
ministre des transports américain
nouveau ministre des transports français
le turbo tra est une arme d'avenir dans
quelle mesure va-t-il entrer rapidement
un service aux particuliers pour
décongestionner bordeaux vous savez j'ai
annoncé l'autre jour à la foire de
périgueux que le tueur votera seraient
en service l'été prochain entre bordeaux
et lyon je crois que c'est une grande
nouvelle pour perry que pour bordeaux et
pour lyon monsieur le ministre
quelles ont été vos premières
constatations dans ce nouveau prototype
français de train
[Musique]
très impressionné il n'y a pas
d'équivalent en amérique ici et j'espère
avoir des trains de souge ans et à
risque dans les régions en trafic
américaine
est ce que les états unis seraient
intéressés éventuellement par le turbo
trains français roddy white wentzel by
the french touch ring
yes we would be oui serait intéressant à
bien
hier soir nouvelle spectaculaire
victimes de l'austérité
l'aérotrain qui devait relier la défense
à cergy pontoise
le projet a tout simplement été
abandonnée l'aérotrain cergy la défense
ne sera pas construit le projet est
abandonné nouvelle victime de la
politique d'austérité du gouvernement
la décision de construire une ligne
rapide entre la ville nouvelle de
pontoise cergy et le quartier de la
défense avaient été prises en 1971
c'est la technique du coussin d'air
appliquée aux véhicules de transport en
commun et expérimenté à orléans qui
avait été retenu pour les 26 kilomètres
du projet deux raisons majeures à ce
choix assurer nos liaisons pratique avec
une ville nouvelle
pôle d'attraction de la région
parisienne est présenté aux étrangers
plusieurs pays sont intéressés par le
système
une ligne dans des conditions réelles
d'exploitation
très vite pourtant des difficultés
étaient apparus surtout dans la mise au
point du mode de propulsion choisi le
moteur électrique linéaire de conception
révolutionnaire le moteur linéaire ne
pouvait être prêt avant 5 en difficulté
aussi avec les riverains notamment dans
les yvelines qui se plaignait de voir
passer un aérotrain coupant les communes
en 2 sans pour autant en bénéficier ces
difficultés auront donc eu raison d'un
projet contesté retardé et dont le coût
suivait les augmentations tous ordres on
l'estimait déjà cette année à 600
millions de francs
il reste à l'ingénieur bertin père de
l'aérotrain et du coussin d'air à
trouver d'autres applications pour son
système en france et hors des frontières
dès à présent ils s'y emploient
convaincu dit-il de défendre une
technique d'avenir
c'est un instrument qui circulent à très
grande vitesse mais transportent nombre
limité de passagers
je n'ai donc pas un moyen de transport
idéal sur des zones de banlieue et sont
l'établissement sur la ligne de cergy
pontoise à la défense ne correspondait
pas à ce qui est nécessaire pour cette
zone quitte à transporter un très grand
nombre de passagers avec une très grande
fréquence et avec des arrêts nombreux
j'imagine au contraire que sur une ligne
comme roissy orly le contournant la
périphérie parisienne l'aérotrain
pourrait correspondre éventuellement à
une justification normale ce qui
caractérise l'aérotrain c'est la
sustentation sur coussin d'air
c'est à dire que le véhicule n'est pas
portée par des roues reposant sur des
rails mais qu'il aimait dg d'air qui le
font en quelque sorte flotter au dessus
de son rail l'aérotrain que nous voyons
ici à l'essai et le modèle pour longue
distance il est propulsé par un réacteur
et il a déjà dépassé 400 kilomètres à
l'heure l'aérotrain qui devait assurer
la liaison cergy-pontoise la défense
souhaite une vingtaine de kilomètres
devait lui être propulsée par un moteur
électrique linéaire plus propre et plus
silencieux mais la réalisation de ce
moteur a posé de nombreux problèmes
techniques
c'est ainsi que sa construction d'abord
confié à la firme merlin gerin avait
ensuite été confié à la firme jeu manche
naître après l'abandon de la ligne
cergy-pontoise la défense le problème se
pose de savoir si l'on va continuer à
développer cette technique mais pour
d'autres le gazon ou bien si on devra y
renoncer
jean bertin avait déposé en 20 ans le
total de 3000 brevets d'invention son
imagination débordante touché la
dissipation du brouillard sur les
aéroports
l'effeuilleuse d'artichaut les
silencieux pour avions mais le procédé
qui l'avait fait connaître au grand
public reposait sur l'utilisation du
coussin d'air
l'ancien responsable des réacteurs de la
snecma pensais tout simplement avoir
découvert la technique qui succéderait à
la roue plusieurs fois millénaire son
principe faire reposer le poids de
l'engin de transport sur l'ensemble de
la surface par des jets d'air assurant
une portance parfaite
il ne restait plus qu'à assurer la
mobilité de l'appareil par ellis ou
turbine le système bertin du coussin
d'air connaît un certain succès sur mer
c'est le na'vi plane ou hovercraft par
contre malgré des années d'essais malgré
un encouragement de l'aménagement du
territoire à l'origine l'aérotrain
systèmes urbains ou intervilles guidé
par un rail de béton ne plus dépasser le
stade du prototype
un temps prévu sur le parcours la
défense cergy pontoise
il fut abandonné par l'état l'an dernier
père du projet cerveau qui vivait avec
ses inventions jean bertin ne s'était
jamais vraiment remis de ce coup
terrible il laissera le souvenir rare
d'un technicien qui essayait de
convaincre par le coeur une question est
posée à présent l'aérotrain lui
survivra-t-il ou rejoindre at il comme
d'autres innovations françaises au cours
des temps le musée des occasions perdues
le conseil d'état se prononcera demain
sur l'utilité publique du projet de
ligne à grande vitesse paris lyon le tgv
sans attendre son avis dont il ya tout
lieu de penser qu'il sera positif
la sncf vient de passer la première
commande du matériel roulant destiné à
l'équipement de la nouvelle ligne
chaque rame comportera deux motrices
encadrant deux voitures de première et
deuxième classe offrant au total 382
places assises vitesse de pointe 300
kilomètres à l'heure mais la lueur de
croisière sera limité dans un premier
temps à 260 km à l'heure une performance
qui mettra dans six ans lyon à deux
heures et dijon à 1h37 de paris
l'utilité du projet est vivement
contesté par des associations pour la
protection de la nature
leurs critiques sont réfutés par la sncf
qui affirme que l'emprise d'une voie
ferrée est très étroite et consomme dont
peu d'hectares le tgv traversera la
bourgogne sur 265 km et immobilisera
1600 hectares dans l'yonne en côte d'or
et en saône et loire
[Musique]
je ne suis pas né dans une gare vous
serez plus il j'aurais pu les nets
puisque mon père était chef de gare
lorsque je suis né et j'ai connu dans
mon enfance et bien le climat
l'atmosphère des trains à l'arrivée des
trains en partance ce remue-ménage des
hommes ceux qui travaillaient les
voyageurs c'est une poésie
vous venez de l'évoquer qui me marquent
encore des concessions
[Musique]